a multi-million dollar boost is heading
into the pockets of small businesses in
nevada
today the governor approved 50 million
additional dollars for the pets program
christian castro is joining us live from
the newsroom with what this could mean
for local businesses
who really are barely hanging on that's
right brian well i talked to a flower
shop in north las vegas today and the
owner says that they're doing
everything that they can to survive
normally they depend on holidays like
valentine's day but this year
that's not the case now princess flowers
on steward and lamb has been operating
for two years
but the momentum was cut short last year
when the pandemic hit
a reduction of delivery personnel and
staff hours were stretched out
for their operations for months the
owner tells me they've applied
for a variety of economical aid but
they've either
been basically in a status pending or
they just simply didn't qualify
word about the available additional
funds in the pandemic emergency
technical support or pets program
was a sign of relief for all the flower
shop staff who say their sales
temporarily shifted
because of covet we went down a little
bit in the regular orders but we have
more funeral orders like
more weight like we used to have just
few a week now
it's most of our orders are funeral or
sympathy
or get well you know about the virus
well the governor's 50 million
additional dollar approval of pets
program raises the program funding to
more than a hundred million dollars
the money can be used for rent inventory
payroll or utilities among others
and geared towards businesses like bars
pubs restaurants and other businesses
now to qualify you must have an active
business demonstrate financial hardship
due to covet 19
have no more than 50 employees and under
4 million dollars
in annual revenue now you might notice
that the pets program website
reads application is closed we are told
new funds will basically be going over
to those pending applications a grant
provides up to ten thousand dollars to
small businesses and more than 14 000
applications
were submitted since the program opened
in october a helping hand
that the flower shop hopes to get
christian casa is eight news now